the rap thing is going excellent for me
but if not I'm gonna hook up with you
all right and you can sling some ice
cream they go by two chains two chains
I'm over the top sometimes and right now
we're going to check out the most
expensive [ __ ] [ __ ] definitely crazy
way back to chains most expensive [ __ ]
[ __ ] and today we're gonna really really
blow your [ __ ] brains up an ice cream
sundae no joke you don't even have to
cook an ice cream and it still cost a
[ __ ] arm and a leg let's get into it
Jojo my man good to see you again we got
something really blinged out for you
today
this is the golden opulence sundae you
know I need these words from golden
opulence sundae tell me buddy what's on
what's going on well it's the most
expensive ice cream sundae in the world
it's this a record holder this is a
record holder still a record holder a
glass that it's in it's the same goblet
that they use in the bathroom this is
baccarat crystal from France
I'm baccarat yeah then inside we have
ice cream but not just any kind of ice
cream we have Tahitian vanilla ice cream
and we infuse it with Madagascar vanilla
then we roll it in old what's going on
with this gold and that you can eat to
them about that you can eat pure gold
doesn't have a taste but it has a real
cool texture and there's nothing cooler
than eating gold then we add some of the
most expensive chocolate in the world
some of the rarest chocolate in the
world candy fruit these are little
candied fruit from without Sean in Paris
and these are made with gorgeous fresh
fruit soaked in a sugar solution for
about a month
it's throat rich then there's turn to
candy so it's good for you absolutely
then we top that with this flour which
is totally made of sugar and it's dipped
in gold and it's totally edible this
flour flour is edible
it looks like an orchid right and on top
we have the world's only dessert caviar
salt free caviar infused with passion
fruit and omnia and of course you eat it
with [ __ ] ghost bones I go out eat a
lot and I've take a lot of the
silverware with me that's just my thing
so is this a situation where you're
missing a few spoons ah these were real
careful about the range run
how much is this Sunday worth how much
is this Sunday for the record holding
champion like yourself joke what is this
Sunday 10 with the cost of a writer I'm
sure probably eat them every week one
thousand dollars and you get to keep the
glass oh [ __ ]
you should've able to borrow the
restaurant for a thousand dollars
what's that you know how much $1,000 do
people come eat this thousand dollar
shell at least once a week
seriously that's what you'd really talk
about having expensive tastes
this [ __ ] is gonna melt if I don't eat
it so I'm about to eat and go yeah
I can eat all this mm-hmm
dig in circuits get some of that
chocolate all this element all that
cutter this is nice job hit my phone bro
yeah I'm always available I'm always
always having the munchies this should
have a frame around you yeah so I feel
like this is a piece of art I feel like
this is eating art most people come in
take a photograph of it first listen
listen listen listen pay attention to me
the man said that he sells one a week
ice-cream sundae which is 52 thousand a
year I've already done the math so in my
eyes those are good numbers
you think it's really birthday talk to
him leave a comment subscribe to the GQ
chunk for more most expensive [ __ ]